hello welcome to this video a beautiful
mind let's play all night lecture and
write or Lant alert sure it's always
difficult all night or not ok let's go
for something else there Chang I've
played a couple of pool goes I think
against him vocals Catalan something
like that Queen takes Bishop c3 ok
galaxy on like a symmetrical English
just with them some twists where to go
h5 ridiculous and probably I don't know
maybe maybe not a great idea maybe I can
provoke him to go G 4 I mean it would be
actually nice hmm so I can I do
something crazy there and sacrifice it's
probably entirely incorrect right but I
loose against this is nonsense all of
the time so maybe it got better try so
how's my plane yeah I want well the plan
is easy it's made it's as it should be
but a five and one you can take my porn
on b7 that actually is yeah probly good
check
and if I'd ever but you can take b7
that's the problem really my night has
no kind of protection 94 also does not
work then we have to go here as weird as
it looks at least at the strength while
a little bit and there before next time
getting some stuff back oh ok
I can take with the night then my cheeks
f8f cheeks ok oh ok well yeah I choose
my own but what told you what is the
right word for that it was my own doing
and what what happened to him this game
ok so
94 some some strategic some position
move this win here unfortunately
don't even have a threat here 97 I mean
I do not have any material left even
that wins
that's City night or day five okay that
that sacrifice was entirely I mean that
was just completely it was just utterly
stupid it did not work in the in the
slightest I mean not a little bit now
you can take fa them given and it all
wins it all wins
I have no attack and only he can do
something it's the problem okay I'm
taking this chant really matter check
24s easiest check yeah yeah I works is
seven ok so this was one of the most
ridiculous p sacrifices that i ever
played you mean my gosh is entirely
stupid okay i should just go to a five
or whatever and play a normal position
be happy that he has weakened himself a
little bit and i was just not working at
all and I should probably if I I mean
okay it is not good nothing okay but I
should at least keep that pawn and and
play I mean this is not that easy
because it's two pawns and his king is a
little bit shaky the the way it went
with that f5 I was just completely my
whole structure got killed and I was so
she material yet oh let it absolutely
made no sense oh ah ok well I think I
probably should stop this session ok
thanks for watching